what's up chris and matt uh my name is
norma jean i'm from southern oregon
it's my dog um i have some breakup
advice
question for you guys i
am
30 and going through my first breakup in
a very long time i spent
most of my 20s single and haven't been
through a breakup in a long time and i
need my community a lot
and i think i'm making the right choice
and man i keep trying to do this video
without crying but pity um breakups are
sad and um
i don't want to wear my friends out with
it but i do need them
and
you know i guess my question is when do
i know that my friends are [ __ ] sick
of it
is there like a timeline like you get 30
days
um
just maybe some general rules about
breakups and how you guys approach them
and how you support friends and breakups
and um
maybe some words uh
thanks for the podcast
and i look forward to hearing from you
guys thanks
that's my favorite person that has
called into the show so far yeah you
like the realness of it yeah um
so i think that they're not your friend
if they get sick of your thing about
being broken up it doesn't there is no
[ __ ] time limit there is no nothing
if you're if your friends are like oh my
god she's going on again about the
breakup i actually think they're not
really that good yeah yeah yeah i've had
friends that have gone on and on and on
about it for [ __ ] months and months
and months right and i'll tell you this
though i mean this ought to make you
feel good
it's just true though i'm not trying to
make you feel good
it always ends up the same way
the person [ __ ] moves on and forgets
and ends up was with someone else
and that is a better relationship that's
happened to every single [ __ ] time
me me or any of my friends who have come
to me about breakup advice yeah or
wanted just to [ __ ] wallow about the
breakup it's always the case
that they end up not only forgetting
about it but in a relationship that they
are better off in so my advice to you is
don't worry about wearing your friends
out
that's it yeah well this is your time
right yeah exactly like like i guess
that's what i would say like you're this
is what your friends are here for if
you're if you're not building up like
goodwill with your friends and [ __ ]
being friends to them then this is your
time where you get to only worry about
yourself
worry about yourself but also like just
worry about yourself take some [ __ ]
me time i hate when people say that but
you know i have a feeling probably you
know
you couldn't get through this video
without crying because of the realness
but also because you i noticed you have
a dream catcher a lot of women who dream
catchers cry more normal than women who
don't have to here's my question yeah
what
is a dream catcher it's the thing in the
back that was a circle that people hang
on their car if you have some people
have a lot of people have two they'll
have one in their room and then one in
their car and they're on their
windshield those people cry a lot okay
are you talking [ __ ] about her i mean
i'm lightly just having fun okay but
also careful though because if you talk
[ __ ] no i love it
with overalls
and also she's very she's obviously very
sweet and also crying isn't bad crying
is great no crying is great but like
here's the deal though
where's the cut off and i'm gonna play
devil's advocate because i understand
you're like it doesn't matter how long
but where's the cutoff
six months okay a year bro if my buddy
was like man this chick you're a year
and a half later it sounds like it's
recent okay and i'm on her side and i
think that you should talk about it with
your friends as much as you want and i'm
sure they want to be there for you too
because if they're not going to be there
for the shitty friends yes right but
also where's the cut off
well she's not going to be wallowing for
a year look look at her she's [ __ ]
great she's going to have [ __ ] pick
of the litter in no time i know but i'm
just saying
there's got to be some sort of cutoff
give yourself a [ __ ] cut off too you
can do that i mean if you're just
talking about when this also just i
think broadly the broader advice here
is that
don't
she said a month
she was like a month she said it is a
month too long oh no
way longer yeah yeah but my advice to
you is don't worry about when the end is
going to come because when you're
worrying about when the end is going to
come that's when the end never prolongs
the end you just spoke over me very very
very poignant and that's a lot like john
lennon and john lennon once said stop
bringing up john lennon quotes you don't
even know all right you always do this
he said something about like
you always bring up [ __ ] john lennon you
don't even know what it was dude
something about time i can't [ __ ]
remember oh yeah okay you don't even
remember any more words than i don't
know much about john lennon i'm just
saying no [ __ ] somebody out there said
something really [ __ ] poignant about
something that what you're saying and
they said it probably better than you
did no i said it [ __ ] great yeah and
you spoke over it okay
don't worry about when the end is gonna
come when you're worrying about when the
end is gonna come the end never comes
just [ __ ] hang out with your dog hang
out with your friends talk about it as
much as you want think about whatever
the [ __ ] you wanna think about but don't
think about when the end's going to come
because that is when the end will never
[ __ ] come get it it doesn't matter
i'm not saying stop thinking about it
you think about what you think about but
don't try to hurry it the [ __ ] up it's
going to come when it's going to come
but it's never going to come when you're
worrying about when it's going to come
all right so but then you're saying
think about you're going to think about
what we're going to think about it's
okay for her to think about what she's
thinking about right but it's not okay
for me to be thinking about when i'm
talking about john lennon
and that's shitty right why are you
making it about you i'm not i'm saying
it's okay to think about what you're
going to think about as a person but
also when i mentioned the john lennon
thing you're like don't mention john
lennon but that's what i'm thinking i
only say that about john lennon because
you don't know what the thing john
lennon said is and you say that's like a
thing john lennon said and then you
don't even know what it was you're gonna
be fine bottom line is you you can tell
you're a very sweet woman and you're a
ver you got that dog that's very sweet
and you obviously care and you have some
sort of like um
quality about you that's very like um
[Music]
i mean that dream catcher like it's very
nice to be like believing in things and
like
hoping for the best like it's a very
spiritual kind of a i think you're going
to be well you are going to be fine yeah
she's the best she's the best person
that um okay ask for our advice all
right well she's the very very best okay
sorry to everyone else she's the very
number one best i mean we don't know but
yeah she knows she was definitely good
yeah i know she was a lot better than
the [ __ ] guy with the towel on his
head i'll tell you that much
[Music]